hi there again you have my wife playing
piano in the background she loves to
play the piano
and uh continuing in this series of how
i went about learning different
languages i'm going to talk about
swedish
uh i was born in sweden
i lived there till i was five
so i can only imagine that i only spoke
swedish
um
when we moved to canada
i have no recollection of
sort of transitioning from swedish into
english nowadays they put people in esl
class they have all kinds of
help for
young you know children of immigrants to
learn the language whatever granted
there weren't so many immigrants
but i can't remember transitioning
transitioning from swedish i started the
next year at school
i had friends we played football
everything was normal we spoke english
um
with the result of course that i forgot
my swedish
and at the age of 16 i visited sweden
uh because my mother had died she passed
away quite young from uh cancer
and uh my uncle her brother lived in
sweden so um
my father decided to send me to sweden
to spend some time with my uncle
and my uncle had a son who was 10 years
younger than me so i was 16 and he was
six
at the airport and he came out to meet
me and he was an only child so he was
very excited to see his his only you
know and he had no other relatives in
sweden to see his only cousin
you know older cousin and
and i remember driving home from the
airport because we couldn't communicate
he was crying out of frustration that we
couldn't say anything to each other
but i spent two months in stockholm
my uncle got me a job in a uh the
warehouse of a large department store
where
they would tell me to go and get
something and bring it to the front so
they could load trucks so i did that for
eight hours a day
um earned a bit of money and i heard a
bit of swedish and slow of course they
all spoke english but uh still it was
exposure
and
then subsequent to that i was in as a
student in france in in grenoble
grenoble there were a lot of swedish
girls down there so there's a real
incentive so i spent a fair amount of
time with them so that was very good for
my swedish
um not probably so good for my french
but it was good for my swedish
um
so the whole the swedish thing started
the kind of and i'm sure that that
having heard it for five years as a
child it was you know it helped me
uh but i had a very limited vocabulary
then uh after starting my own company in
1987
we ended up doing business in sweden
uh because we wanted to
uh basically develop you know canadian
lumber spruce and pine we wanted to
grade it to the european specification
so
um
i went to sweden
and found we found a guy who was a
retired mill manager who was willing to
come out
and teach us the canadian mills how to
grade this lumber to european
specifications so i started having this
involvement with sweden
and lo and behold in
1993 there was a dramatic shift in world
lumber markets whereby
we could no longer export from north
america because the prices in north
america were so high
but we could buy in sweden and sell to
japan
so i started doing more and more
business in sweden so then i decided to
really work on improving my swedish not
that i needed to because
the people we dealt with all spoke
english with a few exceptions
but i wanted to really improve my
swedish and basically what i did was
listen and read and the biggest
influence on my swedish by far
was this
herman lindqvist historian omisvaria
history
of sweden okay and
i mean this he writes the most wonderful
popularization of history now it just so
happens that i like history and of
course it's very important that you read
about things that you like
and not only
did he have this book but he also read
his book
so i was able to listen to the book and
read the book and i have listened to
herman lindquist
so much and so many times
and this one is kind of like a summary
uh no this is one of the sections
drummer overclick which is i think the
modern period but he also has one where
he talks about the history of sweden
from the ice age till the future or till
the frontier i guess i don't know what
that is i don't know my vocabulary in
sweden sometimes is lacking the present
day i guess historian um from east t dil
franti
so there you got all this good stuff to
listen to i also got very interested i'd
go to sweden and i just go and buy all
the audiobooks i could find there was an
excellent series on how to make speeches
in swedish and i don't know how many
times i listen to this
and of course everyone then because
there's another one on
charles the 12th
there's one on gustavosa
they even did a thing on napoleon and i
mean these are just some i mean
well done
audiobooks
are so wonderful and i can still
remember when i'm in sweden and i fly
out there in the winter and it's you
know i can't sleep because of the jet
lag i'm up at four o'clock i go jogging
in the snow
listening to
you know
herman lindquist over and over again and
reading and of course when i'm there i
read the newspaper
and um
yeah that was uh that was it now i have
great gaps in my vocabulary in swedish i
would like to at some point really work
on my swedish uh here at link and all
saving the words and working the words
uh but i mean i can work my way through
a history book
uh history books are for me easy to read
because i i i just i'm so interested
that even like in czech as i've
mentioned i read my check history book
i can understand what they're talking
about and so eventually you know you
start to get used to the vocabulary it's
not ideal
more ideal is is i guess what we've done
at link but uh yeah that's basically
swedish uh
undoubtedly helped by the fact that i
grew up i spent the first five years of
my life speaking sweetie but then i
completely forgot it
and now i have an adult vocabulary in
swedish even though there are gaps in it
that i would like to work at so there's
not
much more to say on swedish i ended up
having quite a uh an involvement with
sweden in the timber trade because we
for we still export lumber from sweden
to japan and i would go there two three
times a year and and even though
a lot of the people there speak english
the business people and so forth uh very
often they're happy to speak in their
own language if you speak someone's
language well
people are happy to speak their own
language i often hear this complaint
that people won't speak to me in english
and stuff and there are people like that
but
most people are
most comfortable speaking their own
language and that's certainly what i
found in sweden and i love going there i
like having the act of eat in fact we
had aquavit tonight because uh we often
before dinner
my wife always makes a little hors
d'oeuvre
and tonight
we will take some salmon
and slice it up for sashimi
and i like to pour olive oil
on my uh sashimi
and with a little wasabi of course and
soy sauce and because it's raw
just like in sweden when you have like
gravadlox which is their
cured
you know salmon you have it with aqua
meat so we had a little glass of
activity before we had our meal
uh the main meal was chicken and with
lots of greens and stuff to which we had
a little bit of wine so we had a very
nice meal
but i always have that you know
attachment to many things in sweden
including of course the aquavit the
gravadlocks
and the history the language and all
these things like with every language
that you learn
you bring so much with it so many things
that you can enjoy so there you have it
that's sweet